since a lot of us have experience
opening a business we know how easily
businesses can be ruined by bad rumors
yeah right there's a restaurant Fresno
called Tasty Thai it's it's a you know
family-owned Thai restaurant it's been
open uh six months
suddenly the dudes looking on his Yelp
and he's getting all these reviews like
of people just insulting and berating
them and he's like where is this all
coming from turns out that some lady
some random lady
recorded a video of a dog
tied up to like a post on a neighboring
house to the restaurant and created some
speculation that that restaurant because
it's an Asian restaurant is cooking dog
oh my God nice oh because of this did it
taste doggy was a little doggy it's a
doggy dog world because of this Tasty
Thai after six months is forced to close
no
what what because people stopped going
and the rumors are true did the
community hate them and yeah because the
damage is is already done like the
reputation in it bro what the [__] isn't
that a
defamation it is it is clear but then if
you're doing a defamation case right on
a poor person how like exactly it's like
yeah yeah you pay you paid like 100 G's
for nothing to happen pretty much yeah
because they're not going to be able to
pay it's not like defamation from a
rivaling business it's just a random
regular person that was recording and
was like oh look at this like poor dog
that's being abused so they actually
ended up looking into that dog and the
dog turns out was not abused at all was
fine was just owned by a family in that
house it had nothing to do with the
restaurant whatsoever how sad man but
it's too late I mean that must be a
small community if she knew where the
restaurant owner lived she doesn't know
his restaurant it was right next to the
house next to the restaurant oh it's a
house they're not even Associated that's
how like stupid it is it's like was she
[__] dude yep that's why perception
is everything dude it is the way that
people feel about something is more
important than what is yeah but that
just means there's a whole bunch of
[__] town idiots that took what she
said believed it without question no
proof sounds like America yeah it's like
literally everybody
in the world actually that bad though
you're not in the world it's even worse
because because she's posting it online
most of the people that are leaving
reviews aren't even local to the rest oh
my just people online so they just
believe exactly oh I don't like that
that's probably true they are probably I
think and then of course Yelp dude it's
so hard to contact those [__]
and to get them like the whole review
system on Yelp right it either works
really great or it's the worst [__]
thing ever yeah it's known to be a it's
known to be like uh you have to yeah you
have to pay to remove it they're called
the yup Mafia yeah it's going to be like
a mob basically but it's also
intimidating too because I was trying to
leave a bad review on this place called
Lionheart jitsu and then they were
telling me that I can't leave it because
they can't confirm that I was a customer
there but I'm like
I I shouldn't have to prove that well
the reason why is because we paid extra
to remove that oh okay that's
interesting for protection you pay the
protection fee man somebody complained
that the Lobster at jumbi was horrible
and the skewers were meh and it took me
[__] forever to get that taken yeah I
was like we don't even serve [__]
Lobster lobsters but Joe I'm watching
boba shop all publicity is good the
skewers were met is hilarious as they go
up to the jumbee they're like yeah we'll
take three skewers two lobster rolls
please I don't mind that they're
horrible I just want to try them yeah
yeah yeah yeah I gotta believe it for
myself
like you can get because of like this
like whole system you can get Negative
momentum rolling in a certain way where
your actual objective trajectory is
ruined yeah before they go oh we'll
remove that comment but it's like bro my
restaurant's gone now it's already done
so that's it [__] happened yeah it'll
affect the rating right so some people
don't even get as far as looking at the
comments no they just look at uh one
star why yeah and they just don't go
there right the idea of a jumbee
employee taking a lobster out of a fish
tank you want this one
is so good would you like this with aloe
jelly or Boba and
it's still being horrible that's great
and you know what's crazy I don't need
market price I don't think you can even
deny being on Yelp
yeah let's say I'm going like oh there's
a mom-and-pop donut shop I want to rate
it you someone the consumer could put
them on Yelp oh right and then the the
mom and pop donut shop I don't think
they have the right to blow you know I
don't want to participate in this game
and then remove myself if someone puts
you on you're on now yeah and then so
now you got to play Yelp Mafia how about
the right to face your accuser too like
in a cage
I wouldn't want to murder this lady if I
was the owner of Thai
um what's the place called Tasty Thai is
there any response from the person who
created us [__] so initially when
the reporter confronted that woman who
did that
um what's her name Garcia something
Garcia yeah she she denied making those
statements but it's in the video but
then later it was admitted that she did
indeed insinuated that they were selling
dog meat I want to see her video really
bad the the internet is really Savage
look at that logo somebody could have
easily changed Lao for dog oh
that's the news coverage about it yeah
that's so [__] up so uh but the owner
said he is gonna fight to restore the
rep and like reopen and you know I
suppose there's no gun GoFundMe or
something like that I think there is I
think there might be so if there is
that's fine support it this is one of
those things that I hate my lizard brain
for because like I hear that right and I
go I support that owner yay but then the
idea of me ordering from that place I'm
like
I don't know maybe we'll just try
another place yeah yeah I'll do the
veggies only because it's already been
associated with dog yeah and it's like
but my lizard brain's associated with
two things and so I'm like can I just
get like because once you say it it's in
the it's on the Forefront of your brain
yep the other day I saw
um this this person recording in the
back of a restaurant this guy pulls up
out of a back of a truck right there's a
box pulls up like what looks like a
greyhound there's no head
it's like a um
basically just skinned yeah Greyhound
looking thing right and then they bring
it in and I was like it can't be what I
think it is so I read in the comments
they're like oh that's just lamb that's
just lamb that's just you know Costco
yeah but a lot of people were like
immediately thinking like that's a great
like a [__] Greyhound that's a great
dane especially if you're not a butcher
it's hard to tell but also like would it
be more cost effective to serve dog no
that's the dumbest thing about it like
in the states it wouldn't be dogs like
800 bro like yeah especially eating a
freaking like Frenchy's Great Dane bro
they're expensive kidding me yeah three
grand yeah dude that's the whole thing
about that's a Prime Cut Meat yeah the
negative stereotype of eating dog is
like that all of it's stupid and it's
very like region specific clearly if
someone's doing that they're you know
it's a choice they're making they don't
have cats not because it's cheaper dude
I got a buddy I got a buddy who started
I've actually eaten dog have you but it
was a choice
but you didn't do it because it was
cheaper than a burger hey you weren't in
Fresno okay more exactly it was a
delicacy yeah that's why but a lot of
these places they think like they're
just catching dogs yeah on the street
because it's free right and then killing
those and then serving it at the
restaurant yeah this is where that whole
like racism thing happens right because
then they go oh I'm going to that
[__] Asian restaurant because instead
of feeding you cow they're actually
feeding you dog yeah that sucks that's
just a scam yeah but like I gotta but
the Asians are like why would we ever
give you the more expensive [__] yeah
yeah we we will eat that yeah yeah no no
no the dogs for us
hey what was dog like it wasn't good it
was like a super dry pork oh it was dry
really right yeah all the weird stuff is
like really gamey and dry you got a
souvenir I mean some weird stuff in
Vietnam is it breed specific for like
which which dog to eat or no it's like
General Dog yeah yeah whatever dog yeah
this is dog there's no menu like chow
chow Great Dane oh yeah it's just dog
but um
agricultural dog or something huh just
like a farm animal dog it sucks because
once they're all killed in hairless they
all kind of look the same whether no
matter what kind of dog kind of like a
human right yeah I mean not that I've
seen one but I assume if you burn a
human they all kind of look the same
except for this guys I really love the
fact that like the owner of this
restaurant was watching this video and
initially was like oh thanks guys now
he's like no stop
what happened not in that way
Association yeah it's like whenever you
uh you get accused of great right but
then you're Innocent but everybody still
thinks you're great yeah that's why
smear campaigns work yeah their first
impression is so strong but in politics
it said they say that it doesn't matter
if it's a lie it's like who says it
first that becomes truth in the minds of
people yeah again because I'm an eternal
optimist I'm like well now kinky [__]
[__] love me
here's the original like that's her and
that's her like text that she had
written for her post it says she looks
very very careful yes they have
different dogs every week and then they
disappear sadly Fresno PD nor Humane
what a crazy about saving this poor dog
there's also a market attached to this
house maybe selling the meat to
disturbing but hopefully with this we
are saving a lot more babies please
share share share bro what is she talk
racist [__] what if there's a history
like sauce or something yeah what kind
of meds is she I've been there she has
since apologized and is like urging
people to stop like too late exactly
yeah exactly you need to go work there
for free for like three years yeah but
that kind of does you got a bus tables
does tell you a lot about the climate of
people in general that they're willing
to buy into something this stupid people
just think a gif with text on it is like
some official information yeah I saw
some [__] that's so true about how JFK
Junior's still alive and I'm like what
the [__] are people talking about like a
guy from he's like at a campaign rally
right and like he's like God he looks
kind of like JFK Jr like maybe but JFK
Jr when he died he's like 38 or some
[__] so like this guy's like I don't
know in his 50s he's just like a
handsome older dude but then what they
do is they take a picture of JFK Jr and
they take this guy he's like zoomed in
picture and they put them together it
looks like they're all symmetrical
because they lined it all up together
yeah and people actually fall off that
they go that's JFK Jr is still alive
he's part of a political movement that's
going to change America low-key that
would have got me
that's like those photos where they see
like a 1920s picture of a crowd and one
guy is going like this with something
like this is the phone time traveler
how is he using his phone is that an
iPhone who is he calling it's got three
lenses who else has a phone back then
there's no satellites bro yeah it's not
one right
foreign